battu à montauban battu et c'est toi
c'est vrai débat pourquoi les gens
n'aiment pas un match de légende
elle appela alors il est de plus en plus
ailleurs battu dans l'embarras les
changements sont arrivés ils me disent
est ce que tu ferais mon pote avec
voiture de l'an montrésor c'est une
référence quoi vous répondez quoi
bien sûr je dis on est comme ça on est
on est à fond dans la maison ce week-end
et le week-end dernier j'ai attendu
dimanche comme un conte autres
non
18 heures j'ai attendu c'était un ami en
prendre un verre il m'a dit mettez
personnes à 18h bali 17 enfants je peux
dire la vérité ouais lundi matin on
arrivait à la radio cyril il ya valérie
kiffer alors c'est bien passé que m'a
tuer fait toujours bon j'ai oublié ce
contexte là bas je n'ai pas mes invités
je bave dans les textos pour dire est-ce
que je peux venir chez vous un texto
salut cyril à 17h au moins à je vois
matthieu delormeau et ya ba voila c'est
la règle un poème samedi après mam aussi
facile vous l'avez vous la vente est non
non je n'ai pas en tête puis c'est
gênant c'est comment un commencer
comment bon c'est sûr vous l'avez des
programmes bbx a commencé comment
justement tunisie bon tu déjà fait
c'étaient les rimes riches en rien nos
amis tunisiens c'est rien c'est rien
elle est bourrée débris allaient coup de
gueule c'est bon et s'il vous plait
enlevez le minibar alors coup de gueule
de juive et thierry gillet gillet tirez
vous avez un coup de gueule alors je
vais je demande à thierry démarez parce
que lui le problème c'est que j'ai vu
j'ai vu gilles verdez la corsa par là et
là il arrive le nez en avant tel un
aigle
alors oui en john kelly c est une jeune
blogueuse beauté qui est laid
prochainement candidate dans danse avec
les stars
l appel publié sur son blog des conseils
de beauté sur des masques il ya quelques
semaines alors on a fait 1 à base de
cannelle et le journal 20 minutes au
quotidien 20 minutes a fait un article
parce qu'il ya des gens qui sont pas sur
twitter il ya eu des allergies sont loin
des 1 1
la cannelle absolument il ya un
dermatologue a expliqué que c'était une
plante qui était un peu allergènes et
elle a répondu d'une manière lunaire en
disant tout à coup on a la réponse en
vidéo voulez quoi la face je me la jouer
mais c'est mieux si c'est elle qui passe
de faire un article sur un masque qui
fait quelques brûlures fait des articles
sur comment réduire la guerre ou régler
le problème de la faim dans le monde
en dessous est quels rapports quels
rapports je pense quelle heure dix au
musée du jouet du pauvre hiawatha and so
what
tu veux de chicorée leroux elle est en
train d'apprendre ce que c'est que la
notoriété médiatique elle va être dans
le prime très important sur la première
chaîne d'europe et pour l'instant elle
avait un million deux cent mille
blogueur donc elle a une certaine
responsabilité
beaucoup de jeunes très jeunes filles la
suivent hélas elle comprend ce que c'est
que d'être scruté par les médias alors
l'a dit je commence ça commence à être
insupportable
si avant de poser le pied sur le dance
très jeune on est et ouest gilles verdez
a priori droit qui veut prendre la
défense de enjoy
l'excusé de la jeunesse n'est pas
valable cyril absolument pas va la vie
enjoy phoenix est très suivi oui la
cannelle est un produit dangereux
ah oui vous savez ce que je vais faire
le masque à la cannelle je vais me poser
alors je vous a écouté ou vous a déjà
facile comme ça et je viendrai avec mes
rougeurs non je vous montrerai ce que
c'est que la can on ne le fait pas il ya
déjà que ces rongeurs à chaque fois
c'est irresponsable ce café enjoy
finitude irresponsable elle est suivie
par des milliers des millions de jeunes
oignons 2 millions des millions dans la
province dont il savait que la cause
devait oui est-ce que tu bois
la toile ou pas de temps en temps mais
pas dans l'émission on sait que c'est
dangereux
pourquoi tu continues à en boire voiles
affalées peuvent elle a fait le masque
dont on peut pas savoir si les quotas
les allergies en nature sur des
allergies aux dacquois où il y en a tout
d énergie mais je faisais moi je vous
dis je fais des masques à larissa et
bachelot ça se passe très bien
voilà où vous le conseillez pas aux gens
non le seul plaisir personnel
moi j'ai testé son masque cadre à la
cannelle bien sûr je pas eu alors
aujourd'hui je n'ai pas de chemises
rouges en fait c'est des rougeurs ou
encore de nom et ça a plutôt bien marché
il ya au fil à différents types de
masques on n'est pas là pour parler
beauté mais il ya le fameux masque à
l'oeuf y en a qui réagissent bien à qui
réagissent pas c'est une jeune fille qui
est suivi par plein de gamine qui donne
des tas de conseils beauté aussi très
sympathique
là effectivement ça fait un peu débat en
même temps on n'est pas en train de
parler non plus du confit
israélo-palestinien je trouve rosich ah
non mais je vais prouver mon innocence
oui mais je trouve que sa réponse mais
elle a eu raison de dire qu'il fallait
pas en faire autant des caisses en plus
elle a répondu un article qu'il a
massacré je trouve mais beaucoup trop
par rapport à ce qu'elle a proposé elle
propose un masque de beauté
malheureusement effectivement après
elles sont aussi excuser son blog ça
reste des rougeurs sur certaines mais
c'est bon elle à elle c'est une gamine
de 20 ans qui est soutenu par des cakes
plein de bonnes intentions qui aide
beaucoup jeune fille à s'assumer être
mieux dans son corps faut arrêter d'être
haro sur la tique les a préparés par des
insultes mais l'insulté période elle n'a
insulté personne n'a pas dix connards
non non mais la façon dont elle répond
faut qu'elle s'habitue
effectivement elle soit critiqué le et
pourquoi elle devrait s'habituer pour
bruce ne pas répondre avec ses tripes
parce que plus exposés plus évidemment
tu être critique
cole débat là dessus on a compris en
tout cas chez lui se fait pas de masque
à la cannelle fait un masque avec kamel
ouali si vous voulez mais c'est tout
oh